طب الحديث عن واقع السياسات البريطانيه في
هذه الفتره هل تعيين الريشي سوناك هو
المحطه الطبيعيه لعقود وربما لقرون من
الاندماج الاجتماعي ولا هو قرار اقتصادي
بريجماتي بحث
العضويه او حتى انتخابات عامه بالانتخابات
هل كان سيفوز بانتخابات عامه همم ربما
ولكنه لا اعتقد اننا نستطيع ان نقول انه
فوز كبير للتنوع على حضاري لانه اصبح رئيس
الوزراء لان تعينه لم يكون عبر انتخابات
عامه وعضويه بالعمليه موجوده داخل الحزب
الكثيرون همم
ومثله لحظاتي اوباما شبهوه بها فوزيه
اوباما ولكنه اوباما في الحقيقه فاز
بانتخابات عامه عبر كافه الولايات المتحده
ولكن الامر هنا مختلف تماما
عن حجم العمليه نحن نتحدث عن حزب
المحافظين تحديدا وفي تاريخ هذا الحزب
هناك بعض المواقف المثيره للجدل الاشرنا
اليها في المقدمه مثل خطاب انهار الدم
الذي القاه كما تعرف النائب الراحل
لانقاول الا ترى انه مقولاته الشهيره
الشخص الاسود او الاسيوي لا يصبح انجليزيا
لانه ولد في انجلترا لم تصمد امام الزمن
بالذات امام حزب المحافظين الان او
بخصوصيه حزب المحافظين
طويلا لمده ذلك الوقت كان هناك اندماج
اكبر ومن افضل اشياء تميز بريطانيا هو انا
لدينا نظام قويه من الهويه والقيام التي
يتاخر معها الجميع هي مثل عالميه الولايات
المتحده لديها حكم القانون القائم على
القانون البريطاني والعديد من دول العالم
في اوروبا واسيا وخارجها همم
السادسه ثقافتها على الافكار البريطانيه
مثلا ال الشخص بريء الى ان تثبت ادانته
وهذه فكره بريطانيا و اشياء كثيره اصلها
واصولها من بريطانيا عندما ياتي الاشخاص
الى بريطانيا همم
كثرنا يقولون او حسب
العضو الاسبق في البرلمان انهم لا يمكن
يصبح بريطانيين ولكن الواقع واحده كلها
هذا الاندماج تربيطانيا فقد اصبح هنالك
قالب مختلف ويصبح الشخص بريطانيا حقا